this is the current situation in yemen a
situation where no one is in full
control of the country and where
everyone is at war for their own
interests
yemen has been caught in a vicious war
for more than six years over 230 000
people have died millions are displaced
unfortunately the conflict in yemen is
very similar to a plot worthy of game of
thrones
to use the words of the un the worst
humanitarian catastrophe is undergoing
in yemen the latest u.n report on the
conflict claims more than
377 thousand victims and adds that in
2021 for every nine minutes a child
under the age of five died
as proof save the children reports that
a quarter of all civilian casualties
between 2018 and 2020 were children the
country has been on the brink of famine
for years more than 16 million men is
living constant need of food and basic
necessities that's nearly 65 percent of
the national population in comparison
that's like 38 million italians out of
59 million had serious difficulties in
finding even a single meal a day
according to human rights watch 400 000
children under 5 out of a total of 2
million risk dying of malnutrition if
assistance is not provided all of this
is the product of a war a dirty proxy
war a war so far without winners but
with only losers
[Music]
by the government when people say arming
the saudi no we signed contract country
to country
we purchase we pay money it just goes in
the uk economy and we enhance our
military capabilities no we pay those
contracts if uk decide tomorrow to stop
selling women to the kingdom we will
find another supplier
yemen is one of the oldest inhabited
places on earth a nation with
multifaceted scenic beauty with canyons
deserts oasis and endless unspoiled
coastlines in place of the semitic
origin of its current name the ancient
romans referred to the southernmost
regions of the arabian peninsula as
arabia felix happy arabia an area rich
in spices incense and a trading hub with
africa and india considering what's
happening in yemen today that felix is a
surreal the strait of babel mandeb is a
strategic point for all the trades
connecting the red sea and therefore the
mediterranean with india and southeast
asia and aiden is the city that for
centuries has been the checkpoint to
access the strait the first europeans to
understand this were the british to the
extent that in 1839 the southern
territories of present-day yemen entered
the orbit of the united kingdom the port
of aden was occupied and turned into a
colony while the north of the country
remained under ottoman rule which had
been persistent for over 300 years when
the turkish empire collapsed following
the first world war the north became an
independent kingdom for about 50 years
yemen was split into a more populated
north with its capital cena and an
almost completely uninhabited south
except for the strategic coasts under
british jurisdiction in 1962 a group of
nationalist soldiers supported by the
egyptian president nasser carried out a
coup d'etat in the north market
they occupied the capital senem and
forced the king muhammad al-badr to
abdicate this led to the proclamation of
the arab republic of yemen this episode
triggered a first civil war that would
last until 1970. in this conflict
regional powers didn't stand idle egypt
ended up supporting the new republican
government while syria and saudi arabia
sided with a monarchy for a full 80
years yemen experienced a long painful
taste of what civil war meant
the conflict ended in 1970 when with a
disastrous egyptian retreat the yemeni
royal family was finally forced to
surrender and admit the recognition of
the northern republic in the south
instead the british had already
withdrawn since 1977
due to the pressure exerted by
insurrectionist groups supported by
nasser's egypt the europeans left the
control of aden to a new sovereign state
the people's democratic republic of
south yemen a nation with a
marxist-inspired regime the only one of
its kind in the arabian peninsula the
pro-marxist faction was a factor of
isolation it was viewed with suspicion
by the monarchies of the region after
all yemen is still today the only
republic in the area the arab monarchies
feared the expansion of other
revolutionary movements the cold war
then added fuel to the tensions a bit
like the korean peninsula in germany
yemen was also divided in two the south
being socialist and per soviet didn't
fit the political model of the northern
part and the two short wars between
north and south showed that yemen's
politics hadn't yet come to terms with
its past in 78 there was a plot twist in
the north a colonel of the armed forces
ali abdullah saleh of zaidi shihid
origin came to power and was destined to
remain in charge for over 30 years using
the gcp the general congress of the
people more than a traditional political
party salah quickly became the father of
the nation to pay the costs of the
dictatorship were a dissonance but most
of all the so-called marginalized the
alakdam almost 13
of the yemeni population yemen is in
fact still today a strongly hierarchical
nation with very rigid castes at the top
there are the most fortunate the saddam
the members of the islamic religious
elites the act them are comparable to
real slaves discriminated outcasts of
society to whom are left the most
degrading and demeaning jobs a yemeni
saying describes them in these words if
your plate is touched by a dog clean it
if it's touched by an akdam break it
it is in this broken society that in
1990 during the years of the collapse of
the soviet union the unification of the
two states took place again under the
leadership of the immovable celeb the
however was perceived from the beginning
by the south for what it was an unwanted
annuation through a manipulation of the
electoral system that rewarded the most
densely populated regions there is those
of the north the yemenis of the south
were immediately ousted from the
government from public jobs from the
army from the redistribution of land and
from the energy sector and this despite
the fact that about 80 percent of the
oil and gas fields were located in the
south all of this explains why in 1994
there was an attempt coup by marxist
military and politicians the attempt
coup was unsuccessful but this
oppression led by the north only served
to worsen the situation in the early 90s
in the northwestern region between seda
and the capital sena an organization was
formed originally it was more of a
religious sect founded by the cleric
hussein ahuti being assailed shihid
hussein was very close ideologically and
politically to iran and had very good
relations with its supreme leader ali
khamenei he also had very good
connections with the other shyite
realities in the middle east like the
lebanese hezbollah hussein's movement
was initially called the believing youth
and only after the radicalization
following the harshest relations with
the central government the group took
the name of ansar allah literally the
champions of god also known as the
houthi clashes between saleh forces and
ansar allah erupted in 2004. the houthi
accused the slayer of extreme corruption
of being unable to maintain the
multi-party system of the republic and
of high treason towards the yemen its
people natalie for having opened up to
relations with the saudis who have
always been considered the foreigners
and invaders but also for having turned
to western governments sales hard fist
did the rest many yemenis in the north
supported the ideas backed by the
houthis the inefficiency of the
government and the fear of becoming a
province in the hands of saudi arabia
the traditional cradle of islamic
wahhabism was a great incentive for the
recruitment of new members of ansar
allah not coincidentally the zhadi
shaite minority in yemen is concentrated
in the northwest the territory that's
still in the hands of the houthis and
that for decades has undergone a process
of sunilization by the religious
majority in the country even though not
all zaidi are houthis and not all
houthis are zaidi in the wake of the
alleged arab spring the long reign of
yemen's master father came to an end on
february 27 salah resigned handing over
to his deputy abdrabhi mansur hadi hadi
tried to reach an agreement with the
houthis promising to give them more
political weight and dividing the
country into six federal regions the
houthis however declared themselves
dissatisfied with the proposals and
irritated by the government's announced
decisions to cut subsidies in january
2015 they carried out a coup d'etat led
by general abdullahfiz al-sakov calling
for hadi's resignation in addition to
this the general economic and social
crisis of the country already then the
poorest in the arab world were causing
serious problems such as unemployment
and skyrocketing inflation in a
surprising twist the houthis came back
to whom you don't expect
saleh the houthis wanted political
legitimacy and saleh without a
presidency anymore was willing to grant
it in order to get new prominence
celeste still had military personnel
loyal to him and therefore sent them to
support the rebel offensive despite the
support of foreign allies such as the
saudis the emiratis and the americans
hadi was forced to resign and to leave
power to the interim president of the
parliament a figure considered close to
the former president saleh this time too
the new government wasn't recognized by
the houthis who in february of the same
year declared a parliament this halt
transferred power to a revolutionary
committee and from the north took over
the capital cena this move forced hardy
to make a daring escape and he had no
choice but to take refuge in his native
city aiden in the new institutional
headquarters hardy declared on state
television to be the only legitimate
president of yemen and he disavowed the
coup of the houthis and proclaimed aidan
as the transitional capital in turn the
leader of the shiites abdul malikal
huthi speaking on television publicly
declared his commitment against islamic
terrorists including not only members of
al-qaeda but also had his men but in the
meantime hadi had to take refuge in
riyadh the capital of saudi arabia where
he still lives the houthis actually
managed to enter aden at the beginning
of april 2015 but the city was taken
back by the loyalists in the summer of
the same year at that point the saudis
were really upset i began wondering if
we don't do something now in yemen we're
gonna be in big trouble aside from the
official explanation that is that of
defending an internationally recognized
government the real motivations for the
saudi intervention in yemen were many
saudi arabia was sharing a border of
thousands of kilometers with a nation on
the brink of civil war a nation where
those in danger of coming to power were
shiite clans allied with iran and a
yemen in houthi hands would have meant
ruin for the saudis total isolation the
blockade of the strait of hormuz would
have been followed by that of babel
mondeb and with it goodbye to the
billions of barrels exported to the rest
of the world no exports no petrodollars
no money no power and so the nightmare
of saudi arabia impoverished as a yemen
2.0 could become reality this scenario
was enough for the crown prince bin
salman to financially isolate yemen and
move the army in the northwestern
territories saudi arabia didn't have a
mandate from the u.n security council as
a result many including human rights
watch itself judged their attack as
something illegal and indiscriminate
amnesty international itself in 2018
titled the united states shouldn't take
part in war crimes in yemen the
reference was not only to arm sails but
also to sending mercenaries through the
private military company academy
formerly known as blackwater the
military intervention of the saudis and
emiratis took place mainly through the
air force which bombed several times
sanae and other urban centers with the
aim of blocking the advance of the
houthis in the territory according to
this chart provided by the yemen data
project the peak of coalitionaire
assaults was reached in october 2015
with more than 900 bombings in 30 days
24 600 raids in total since 2015 with an
average of 10 per day so the attacks
have often been non-selective according
to the yemen data project a third of
saudi bombings have hit non-military
areas including hospitals schools and
residential areas as well as funerals
and weddings a clear violation of
international humanitarian law beyond
the official statements since the very
beginning the civil war in yemen has
been a proxy war between the sunni arab
front close to the government of hadi
and the shiite block supported by iran
it's basically a battleground between
the two traditional enemies of the
middle east the alliance that the
houthis weaved with saleh lasted until
2017. saleh offered to end the offensive
if riyadh and abu dhabi promised to lift
the embargo and seize the military
operations the houthis didn't take it
well so much so that not even two days
after the conference solaire was killed
by a sniper while fleeing the capital
complicating this picture was the other
major unknown factor in the territory
akp cells the al-qaeda in the arabian
peninsula formed in 2009 from yemeni and
saudi branches akp took advantage of the
cahoes and protests to spread in the
large province of other mouths in death
of marib and in some coastal areas
carrying out attacks against civilians
and non-civilian targets at this moment
however akp's action has been strongly
buffered by the offensive carried out
with us weapons and drones one of which
neutralized in 2015 the founding head of
the organization nasir al-wayashi
has reportedly killed al qaeda
propaganda chief in a drone strike in
yemen as a result akp cells are no
longer in stable possession of any part
of yemen the counter-terrorist action
has seen the collaboration of the us and
uae the latter allied for the occasion
with israel
in march 2017 as part of the fight
against islamic terrorism the u.s
president donald trump authorized more
than 20 bombings on yemeni al-qaeda
positions and in 2021 the same trump
administration included the houthi in
the list of international terrorist
organizations in 2016 for the record
saudi arabia had also been included by
the u.n in the least containing the
state's guilty of war crimes against
children but in june 2020 its position
was removed after the u.n secretary
general antonio guterres verified that
the saudis had implemented
all measures to protect civilians from
bombing however criticism was widespread
because according to some the un had
ignored some of the issues for instance
the netherlands attempted to submit to
the u.n an international investigation
into human rights violation and war
crimes in yemen however as reported by
middle east eye under pressure from
saudi arabia the us and uk amsterdam had
to withdraw the request the dutch were
motivated by sensible reasons the list
of war crimes and actions against
civilians is long and appalling in many
reports issued by international
organizations numerous violations of war
conventions are documented starting from
the use of prohibited weapons like
cluster bombs it is estimated that since
the start of the war there have been
more than 26 000 bombings many of which
were carried out by the saudis in the
mistaken belief that they would quickly
resolve the conflict with a sword of
blitzkrieg the saudi crown prince
mohammad bin salman is said to have
expressed himself in these terms
speaking in 2015 with the dense cia
director john brennan but as always it
is the innocent who paid the heaviest
price sixty percent of the children can
no longer go to school simply because
almost all the educational institutions
are in ruins while the west far from
stopping this carnage has profited from
the sale of weapons with american drones
or weapons from the british and also as
italians as stated in the report death
by drone from the humanitarian
information portal relief web the
statement made by former u.s president
barack obama in 2013 according to which
military drones would be used only with
the near certainty of not hitting
civilian targets is clearly questioned
as pointed out denying case studies
documented in this report provide
credible evidence of a drone strike
involving 12 people including a pregnant
woman but even the other side of the
coin is not saved from this disgrace
who supplies ansar allah the answer is
rhetorical the shiite front in iran is
the prime suspect iran has always
claimed to support the houthi
politically while denying sending
weapons or drones however the seizure of
ships in the indian ocean sailing under
the iranian flag and containing an
indefinite number of weapons and
ammunition proves the contrary needless
to say even the houthis haven't spared
themselves with war crimes this is
witnessed by the killing of 22 civilians
with katusa rockets launched against
markets and residential areas in the
center of the east or as reported by
human rights watch by the recruitment of
child soldiers and the prohibited use of
landmines iran sees the rebels in yemen
as an axis of resistance against israel
and the united states yet according to
some analysts interviewed by al jazeera
unlike other proxies in iran and syria
the houthis do not take orders from the
iranians they welcome their support but
they are not their dependents and
speaking of sending weapons there has
been no shortage of complaints to major
gun companies
as far as my country is concerned the
observatory diriti found that in the
first half of 2020 the italian
government sent arms to the saudis and
the miratis including pistols and
semi-automatic rifles for a value of 5.3
million euros not counting the bombs and
one could say the same about so many
other western nations but let's go back
to the conflict for a moment
in april 2017 the first fracture became
evident within the loyalist front led by
hadi while remaining faithful to the
alliance against the rebels the southern
governorate raids close to the united
arab emirates gave life to a sort of
autonomous government the transitional
council of the south distinct from that
of a hardy and with a real government in
aden aimed at taking the place of the
legitimate one of sana in any case these
internal contrasts had no influence on
the ongoing conflict while reaching an
agreement on a ceasefire the fighting
never stopped partly because of new
tensions between the us and iran over
the nuclear matter according to the
terms of the jcpoa no nuclear developed
in iran no sanctions by the west to
renegotiate the agreements washington
asked tehran to withdraw its support to
the houthis something it didn't do this
reignited the fightings another key
event was when in 2019 the emirates
matured their decisions to withdraw from
the theater of war the emirates
certainly realized that the war was
detrimental to their own reputation they
quickly noticed the difficulties
encountered by the saudis in the
mountains of northern yemen and they
learned their lesson soon in addition
their objectives differed from the
saudis if the purpose of riyadh was to
reassert by force its role as a regional
power and restore an order that favored
saudi arabia and yemen the emiratis
pursued more the objective of
controlling only a few strategic areas
which they achieved thanks to a dense
network of local alliances they managed
to get an access to ports and coastal
areas such as the port of aden and a
series of minor ports important for the
control of hydrocarbon traffic such as
al-mukhola al-sir rudum balhaf nishtun
and al-gaida to which are added the
islands of socotra and barim which we
have already mentioned in this video the
emiratis have implemented a more shrewd
long-term vision chinese style to put it
another way they have left the dirty
work to the saudis and have chosen
another path to win their own war
establishing commercial bases and
acquiring new positions where the
objectives to be pursued the british
empire mentality precisely that empire
from which the emirates obtained
independence in 1971 to the emiratis the
price of participating in the conflict
far exceeded the benefits and so it was
better to withdraw from what some have
defined as the saudi vietnam to date
according to the words of the american
special envoy tim lander king after
these seven years all parties have
probably matured the awareness of the
impossibility of a military victory in
fact the recent attempt of the houthis
to advance in the marib region rich in
natural resources such as gas and oil
has been completely blocked by
government forces and the drone attacks
against the capital riyadh against the
city of jeddah and against the aramco
plans during the formula one world
championship as well as those against
the emirates airport of abu dhabi have
not had any significant result moreover
the internal situation in the two parts
of yemen is far from peaceful the
houthi-controlled north is characterized
by a highly centralized regime that is
repressive towards any form of descent
and is creating several incidents such
as the raid on the us embassy in sana in
november 2021 where the employees taken
half stage where yemen is and not
americans and things are certainly no
better for the loyalist government in
the south which continues to have
problems with the secessionist
transitional council which controls the
strategic archipelago of social but has
to face in turn the protests of the
population exhausted by years of
suffering and deprivation no electricity
no drinking water and therefore a
cholera epidemic no fuel for cars
unreachable food prices for ordinary
citizens some of whom according to al
jazeera has literally sold their kidneys
at the price of five ten thousand
dollars to get by organs that are then
resold to wealthy clients in other golf
countries at the price of one hundred
thousand dollars
the uncertain future is also given by
the current president at the age of 77
hud is not enjoying good health and at
the beginning of april 2022 he left
power to the presidential council in the
hope of launching a new phase of
transition this phase was welcomed by
the saudis and emiratis who have
announced new financial aid for
reconstruction pacifying the area is of
fundamental importance first of all it
would partially restore the security of
traffic in the red sea let's just think
about the already mentioned strait of
bobby mondeb from which approximately
eight percent of the world's oil
supplies transit or just think about the
possibility of new foreign fighters that
may take advantage of the conflict to
create new terrorist cells if other
reason in favor of peace if ever there
was a need could come from the cooling
relations between the gulf states due to
ukrainian and syrian wars the two
absolute monarchies in fact do not wish
to adhere to sanctions against russia
and increase their production of crude
oil to compensate for the lack of
supplies for moscow not to mention that
the saudis have shown interest in the
possibility of accepting the un instead
of the dollar for sales of crude oil to
the chinese but ending the war without
perhaps the greatest benefit of all
ending an unparalleled catastrophe after
seven years of a forgotten war rarely
mentioned by our media saudi arabia and
the pro-government coalition have never
suffered any sanction despite the
repeating bombing of civilian victims
and in fact the creation of humanitarian
corridors has never been allowed as well
as the current war in ethiopia in tigray
the yemeni one is a very sad example of
the so-called double standard the
atracious symbol of the conflict was
amal hussein the seven-year-old yemeni
girl who died of starvation in a refugee
camp in 2018 just a week after her
photograph went viral and unfortunately
in seven years the un hasn't been able
to find the right strategy to put an end
to the massacre on march 25 the
globalist reported at the moment the
international community has allocated
only 30 percent what the united nation
has called for to respond to the
emergency in 2022 an average of just 15
cents per day per individual inhabitant
it's actually estimated that more than
half of yemenis survive on humanitarian
aid alone
further worsening the situation of
yemenis was the crisis in ukraine given
that about 32 percent of wheat imports
came from ukraine the conflict has
practically blocked imports leading to
an increase in prices starting with the
bread according to undp in 2022 if the
conflict didn't stop yemen would not
only confirm itself as a failed state
like libya or somalia but would also
become the poorest state on the planet
worse than afghanistan and this despite
the presence of rich deposits of
exploitable oil and a strategic position
for commercial traffic made even more
interesting after the scenarios opened
by the crisis in ukraine all of this
would offer important prospects for
development for the country and its
people provided of course that peace is
achieved but to do this one should need
greater media coverage it's clear that
in this war silence serves only to those
who profit from the conflict paulo pizza
the policy advisor for humanitarian
emergencies ethos from italy commenting
on the conflict in yemen spoke of an
international shame adding that what
continues to happen in yemen in the
silence of major international decision
makers is a disgrace that erodes the
very sense of humanity in latin there is
a malta peraspera adastra
through our ships to the stars
that's where i wish for yemen
you